hey everybody i'm joe sasso i'm a chef
here in los angeles and i love pizza i'm
italian so i'm mostly made up of pizza
pizzas in my dna i want to share my love
of pizza with all of you so today i'm
going to show you how to make pizza in
three minutes i'm going to show you how
to make pizza in three hours and if you
have some time i'm going to show you how
to make pizza in three days
so let's get started
we've all been there we've had a long
day at work we get home need pizza on
the fly or maybe even you wake up you're
running late for work you want pizza for
breakfast that's right i said breakfast
you could have pizza anytime i'm going
to show you here how to make pizza in
three minutes and we're going to use
store-bought pizza dough there's nothing
wrong with store-bought products
especially pizza dough they're doing all
of the heavy lifting and hard work for
us so here we have a one-pound ball of
pizza dough i'm using semolina flour to
stop it from sticking here we're going
to divide it
into about four portions i'm going to
put these aside we're gonna use a
rolling pin and flatten this turning it
as we roll it's gonna help make a nice
thin round pizza and don't worry if this
isn't round pizza can be any shape i
have been making pizza since i was a
little kid i think there are photos of
me in the kitchen with my mom playing
with a ball of flour and water so i
consider myself a uh a pizza aficionado
a connoisseur so here we have a nice
round flat pizza not too thin i'm going
to take a fork here and we're going to
do this fancy fancy pastry technique
taking a sharp object everybody has a
fork no special tools required at least
i hope you have a fork unless you have
bigger issues we need to talk about and
that's going to stop the pizza dough
from puffing up too much when we cook it
we'll start out with a little bit of oil
bringing that pan all the way up ripping
hot and we're going to drop this right
down into our hot pan to get a quick
sizzle we're avoiding the oven entirely
on this one i'm gonna turn the pizza
just a little bit make sure we're
cooking evenly pushing it down the more
contact with the hot oil the crispier
the pizza will get flip that over we got
a couple minutes on each side nice
golden brown you could hear that crunch
now we're getting a little bit of finish
on the other side and we're going to
check the other side and oh my god that
is perfect i like to put it onto a wire
rack that lets the steam kind of escape
from the bottom and you don't have to
worry about your pizza sogging out i
have some flaky sea salt here hot out of
the pan all the pores are nice and open
getting that salt in there and then
we're ready to top our pizza i'm gonna
start here
with tomato sauce i chose tomato sauce
versus crushed tomatoes or just whole
canned tomatoes because tomato sauce is
already cooked we're not baking this
pizza so this is pretty much should be
ready to go get a nice little base down
there i'm leaving a tiny little rim i'm
going parmesan here parmesan is
delicious even if it is unmelted and
with me more cheese is better
we have a little bit of fresh chopped
parsley that's gonna give us a nice
herbaceous note some freshness garlic
chips i'm gonna put those right on top
and there you have it homemade pizza in
only three minutes i'm excited to get in
here and try this slice this bad boy up
let's get in there
holds nice a little bit of a droop
that's really good
a little bit of toastiness on the bottom
parmesan is perfect uh the king of
cheeses i'd eat this any night of the
week but you know what if you have some
more time i got a three hour pizza too
all right let's imagine you have a
little more time on your hands you got
someone special coming over tonight
maybe you have a date three hours that's
all you need this is the pizza dough for
you we have bread flour here bread flour
a little different than all-purpose
flour it has a little more protein in
there which is going to help for a
sturdier dough we have olive oil water
sugar salt and in this case i'm using
instant yeast not active yeast instant
yeast can go right into the flour low
speed first
we're going to slowly drizzle in our
water and oil and this will mix we're
gonna keep that on low for about two
minutes
just so you don't end up covered in
flour if you put this right on high
flour explosion all over the kitchen not
what you want to spend three hours
cleaning up on we're gonna bump this up
to medium speed and really just let this
do its thing the flour is going to mix
with the water everything's gonna become
hydrated we're developing gluten now at
this point gluten is gonna help give the
dough structure as well as provide a
nice bit of texture
our dough has been mixing for about six
minutes or so it's starting to slap the
edges of the bowl we're going to
transfer it to a bowl to rest i like to
oil the bowl a little bit of olive oil
get that all around plus oil on your
hands is uh good for you moisturizing
the italian way all right so we're gonna
transfer our dough ball to our bowl to
rest
a kitchen towel so we don't get a skin
to form and we're going to set this
aside for one and a half hours
all right an hour and a half has passed
i've been standing here patiently
waiting but this is my favorite part
pulling off my kitchen towel seeing the
beautifully proof dough and what we're
gonna do here is take this very
carefully out of the bowl and we're
gonna reshape this so i'm actually just
going to fold in the bottom and using
the surface tension creating a nice
round smooth top pinching and sealing
the bottom and then we're going to place
this right back into our bowl to rest
and recover with a towel i'll see you in
30 minutes all right we're back this
dough
is just about ready i'm going to put a
little bit of oil down here carefully
pull the dough out of the bowl and
eyeball
this into two half of this is gonna go
back into my bowl i'm gonna save that
for later we're gonna do pan style pizza
here for this one get some oil down
transfer my pizza dough to the pan
really just kind of spread it out here
leave a little bit of a rim as a crust
and now
time for the toppings i'm using crushed
tomatoes here rather than tomato sauce
they're raw spread nice and even then we
have mozzarella i like to rip it up with
my hands and really kind of just get it
on there in pieces i like having these
big pockets of mozzarella and that keeps
things interesting stick this into our
425 degree oven depending on your oven
at home 15 20 minutes you'll be able to
tell when it's done all right right out
of the oven i'm just going to finish it
off on the pan a little bit of flaky sea
salt on here and classic margarita style
just some nice pieces of basil there you
have it a three hour margherita pizza
ready to eat i'm actually going to use
scissors to cut this one up because this
long rectangle shape reminds me of the
way they do pizza in rome they cut it
with scissors you tell them how big of a
slice you'd like and you pay for as big
of a piece as you get i want to make
sure i get a little basil on there oh
man this came out awesome
i'll tell you what
that extra time from three minutes to
three hours night and day difference
that's awesome really really good uh
crust
really nice structure when you want to
eat the crust alone
that's a really good sign a lot of
people have that crust graveyard on the
side that won't be the case with this
dough even just three hours is enough
time for that yeast to really kind of do
some work get a little bit of fermented
flavor in there you kind of got that
acidity from the tomato sauce man can
you put anything on this but
i think margarita is the way to go all
right this is awesome but if you really
want to go down that pizza rabbit hole i
got a three-day dough that i use in the
restaurant that you need to try
so you have a lot of time on your hands
you really want to get into this
three-day pizza dough this actually
happened as an accident it started as a
one-day pizza dough but actually it was
forgotten about and it turned out three
days is a much better time you get a
longer fermentation you get more flavor
into it so we're going to start with
pizza flour here it has a good hydration
ratio good protein content all that
lends to a better and more perfect
gluten formation so pizza flour into our
mixer get that all in there next we have
once again instant yeast we got sugar
that's going to feed the yeast and olive
oil we'll go into our room temperature
water we're going to start this on low
speed
and we're going to slowly add all of our
water
making pizza dough is easy you let the
mixer do all of the work for you and
once all that flour gets incorporated
you could turn up the speed a little bit
and we're going to let this go for about
five minutes
all right our dough is looking great
kind of take this all down off the hook
and we're gonna let it rest cover it
with a towel and just let it hang out on
the counter 30 minutes yeast is getting
active our flour is hydrating now we can
add all of our salt and we're going to
put this back onto the mixer about
another five minutes here medium low
speed just to get that salt incorporated
all right things are looking good we're
gonna scrape down all of this dough and
then we're going to get it to rest put
it to bed if you will a little bit of
olive oil in our bowl and that we're
just going to plop right down in there
this is going to go in the fridge 24
hours
see you tomorrow my precious
all right it's been 24 hours it is time
to portion and shape our dough balls now
before we pull the dough out non-stick
spray is going to be my best friend i
like to get it down a little bit on
everything i don't like to add more
flour at this point because more flour
is actually going to be unhydrated and
unworked when the non-stick spray is not
going to add anything to the dough i
like to kind of stretch it out a little
bit i like to go about
240 grams so then we're going to shape
these same thing as before pulling the
dough down under itself
in a nice tight top twisting the bottom
almost like a steam bun
nice round dough ball and that is going
to rest like that all right this i'm
going to wrap plastic wrap 24 hours back
in the fridge and get started on my
sausage a good italian sausage always
starts with some fennel seed and we're
going to get it onto a sheet pan i'm
going to get it into the oven about 350
for five minutes till it just starts to
smell fragrant and aromatic fennel super
easy to toast five minutes in the oven
i'm gonna go ahead and get this right
into a mortar and pestle just cracking
open all these fennel seeds
if you don't have one of these mortar
and pencils because you're not as fancy
go ahead and use a plastic bag
zip it closed and smash it with a
rolling pin a pan
whatever you got now i like to leave a
little bit of chunks in there a little
bit of texture and we're gonna get on to
making the sausage so i got some pork
butt here it is not the actual butt of
the pig it's actually the shoulder it
has an ideal ratio of fat to lean meat
dice that up i have my toasted fennel
seed we're just gonna add all of our
spices and aromatics a little bit of
chili flake
a little bit of chopped rosemary a
little bit of parsley italian flat leaf
some finely grated
garlic and a little bit of paprika
starting to get everything all mixed
together a little bit of fresh cracked
black pepper
and then this is actually going to
marinate overnight in the fridge you
could grind this right now but trust me
it's so much better if you let it sit
overnight
our pork shoulder has been marinating i
got a little bit of salt here we're
going to add that to the meat before we
grind it if you don't have one of these
you can use a food processor it's not
going to be exactly the same but it'll
be close enough things are looking good
you can actually turn this up a little
bit
and we can grind faster and all of our
meat has been ground we don't have
sausage yet we have deliciously seasoned
ground pork the once we emulsify the fat
and the protein together we will have
sausage i like to bring this to a medium
speed good italian red wine
slowly drizzle that in we're just
bringing together the sausage meat till
just it starts to stick to the side of
the bowl
and we're there now we have italian
sausage so what i like to do here is uh
get a little pre-cook on it i got my
broiler preheated and we're gonna get a
quick cook on this guy in the broiler
get a little bit of color and kind of
jump start the entire process so that
way when it goes on to the pizza it's
already partially cooked all right this
dough has been resting for three days i
brought this out about three hours ago
to let that proof come to room
temperature finish rising that last hour
i had a cast iron pan in my oven as hot
as it goes i'm gonna try to replicate
a wood oven that you would find in a
restaurant but here in a home kitchen so
we're gonna shape our pizza i like to
get a little bit of flour on top a
little bit of flour on where i'm working
and then the trick here is really going
to be to keep this in its round as shape
as possible
when you're transferring it to
your work surface start by giving myself
a little bit of a crust here then you
kind of push the center out and at this
point i like to pick it up using my
knuckles and the weight of the dough
itself
to get a nice stretch on it and
everything from here on out is going to
happen really fast all my toppings are
ready my pan preheated in the oven you
can just feel the heat coming off of
that screaming hot we're gonna slide
this
into the pan and then we're gonna go on
with the toppings here i have my crushed
raw tomatoes i crushed these by hand to
make it a little more
rustic shredded mozzarella
and the faster you can do this the
better because you want to get this
right back into the oven then i have my
sausage here just going to crumble that
up and last but not least a couple of
pieces of basil kind of cooks into the
pizza and we're gonna go pop this back
into my oven
all right we have our finished pizza
here
you know what people are always looking
for that restaurant
quality pizza without a restaurant pizza
oven and i really think this is the way
to get it i always like to
finish
my pizza crust with a little bit of
olive oil here when it gives it a nice
little sheen and it tastes a little
better a little bit of flaky salt down
around the crust
and you have three day
pizza this looks amazing it smells
awesome i can't wait to get into this i
can hear the nice crunch of the crust i
don't think it's gonna get much further
than four pieces so i'm gonna
dive right in here
give it a nice little fold
first thoughts
totally worth it three days is not a
long time to wait for pizza this good
it's got a really nice chew to it
developed a lot of flavor awesome
texture cooking in the past iron pan
give you a nice crispy bottom and a
sausage on top that's good enough i put
it on my shoes and eat it this pizza it
might take three days but to me totally
worth the effort we've covered a lot we
have a three minute pizza if you're on
the fly we have a three hour pizza
whether you're cooking for someone
special or if you really want the
ultimate three-day pizza with homemade
italian sausage no matter how much time
you have i believe you should always
have time for pizza let me know which is
your favorite in the comments
thanks for joining
[Music]
you